but today the White House seemed to put
some more stipulations on this
scheduling of this meeting we begin as
we do most nights with chief White House
correspondent John Roberts live on the
North Lawn good evening John Brett good
evening to you in a phone call to me
last November President Trump said all
these people are saying I want to start
a war I'm not trying to start a war I'm
trying to prevent one and now critics
who were angry over president Trump's
get-tough approach to North Korea are
saying well maybe he was right
South Korean officials credited the
president's maximum pressure campaign
for bringing North Korea to the table
and the press secretary happily agreed
for the first time in a long time the
United States is actually having
conversations from a position of
strength not a position of weakness like
the one that North Korea finds itself in
due to the maximum pressure campaign the
turnaround was nothing short of stunning
the two leaders had traded insults for
months president Trump calling Kim a
maniac little rocket man
Kim firing back that president Trump was
a mentally deranged dotard while the
White House says this possible
breakthrough was months in the making
even the Secretary of State was taken
aback by how quickly the landscape
changed
[Music]
White House officials don't know
precisely why Kim did an about-face but
they believe the sting of sanctions was
crippling the regime reaction to the
announcement was almost universally
positive in the Sylvania first and
foremost we believe that this step is in
the right direction
certainly it is required to normalize
the situation around the Korean
Peninsula the promise of a one-on-one
meeting with President Trump is a
victory for Kim jong-un but the White
House warning today Kim is not going to
get a face-to-face with the president
unless he's prepared to give up his
nuclear program let's be very clear the
United States has made zero concessions
but North Korea has made some promises
and again these this meeting won't take
place without concrete actions that
match the promises that have been made
by North Korea president Trump is fully
aware that the offer from Kim jong-un
could be just another ruse to buy time
to complete his nuclear program senator
marco rubio is very skeptical laying out
what he really thinks he may be up to
he's luring us into these negotiations
but then he will make demands that he
knows we can never agree to like the
u.s. abandoning South Korea at that
point he will go to the world and say
look I've been very reasonable I met
with the president I've been willing to
be flexible but these guys don't want to
deal with me and that is designed to get
the international community to back off
of sanctions as the world considers the
potential for a historic u.s. North
Korea by lat the attorney for Pornstar
stormy Daniels tried to turn up the heat
today revealing that the president's
personal attorney Michael Cohen had used
a trump organization email to negotiate
a non-disclosure agreement with daniels
the email address was not connected to
the Trump campaign but Daniels attorney
Michael avenatti insists it's further
evidence president Trump must have known
about the agreement in a statement to
Fox News saying once again the idea that
mr. Cohen was doing this for his client
mr. Trump but mr. Trump knew nothing
about it is ridiculous nonsense
unbelievable ludicrous and preposterous
the list goes on and on Cohen told Fox
News what email you use is not relevant
at morning Daniels she's not going to
get out of the gag order saying the
agreements
for itself on North Korea one of the big
remaining questions is where could a
meeting take place White House officials
who were trying to work out a location
say it's complicated it likely wouldn't
be North Korea or the United States or
South Korea or China more likely some
neutral third country Brett
John Roberts loving the North Lawn John
thanks